votre gilet de sauvetage se trouve dans
une pochette sous votre siège si son
utilisation s'avère nécessaire
amener les sangles autour de votre
taille tirer sur les sangles jusqu'à ce
que le gilet soit bien ajusté comme nous
vous le montre merci de votre attention
nous allons bientôt décoller
[Applaudissements]
des événements nous déchire en morceaux
j'aime être sous x c'est ce que ça veut
dire
[Musique]
et quelqu'un il remet en place divers
pourquoi le jeu parfois on peut être ses
alentours et de pleine nature peut-être
cela comment t'est attention qu'est ce
qui te dire que je ne suis pas un seul
type je sais rien
[Musique]
tu es spéciale
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est difficile de tordre heureusement
je pense que je vais finir faire
personne n'utilise son visage public
dans ce champ d'huile
parfois nous masquer plus joli que ce
qui se trouve derrière je me dis qu'il
n'ya pas de fin heureuse
toutes les pièces ne s'emboîtent
parfaitement
et d'un coup tout et pau
[Musique]